well green valley ranch is gearing up
for a special celebration this weekend
it's their 20th anniversary and they are
celebrating in a big way here to fill us
in on all the festivities is executive
chef eric kiefer eric thank you so much
for being here girl thank you for
inviting me it's really great we're
getting the party started early for sure
because all the festivities kick off on
saturday let's talk about some of the
stuff you guys have going on at green
valley ranch so on saturday we do have
our drop bar opening up it'll be a it's
newly renovated awesome cocktail program
should be very unique and and awesome
for that area
also at 9pm we have our fireworks
display that's going on so there's gonna
be a lot of stuff going on in all of our
outlets that's why we kind of brought
some of these uh nice sweet treats to
show you now and so you can kind of get
a head start of what's to come yes this
is getting me excited for the weekend
and you have a fun demonstration here
prepared for us so what are we making
what are we doing yeah so uh in hank's
uh fine steaks and martinis we have our
nutella creme brulee so as i kind of do
this we could talk about also
what we have in some of our other
outlets so uh to our
side right here we have in baracha we
have our uh our chocolate skull is
filled with a bunch of nice little
different treats ice cream whipped cream
all their different candies and you
break it right i've done it before
yes you did break the the valentine's
day yes it's really fun it's always like
a surprise pinata inside of the skull
and then these other things are so
beautiful i love the gold plated what
are those so on the gold wait we got
fire going on there's always something
going on tell me something so in the uh
the gold plating here we have our um
our
breakable ornaments we have our
breakable little uh mr uh santa bear
claws you guys don't think we're all
angry we just want to break things all
the time
around the holiday season so the stress
relievers
exactly we kind of use that stress
reliever okay this is looking amazing
and it smells so good i don't think i've
ever heard of a nutella creme brulee
before yes well it's all the rich
flavors of your typical vanilla bean
creme brulee but what's better than
nutella to add as well so
a little bit sweeter a little bit richer
but everybody loves it it's too dye yeah
you are firing things up over here and
i'm a little distracted by this cotton
candy we have to talk about what this is
in front of us well let's talk about
that now while the sugar kind of cools
down a little bit so this is going to be
kind of our version of the aviation
cocktail but it's made with belvedere
vodka instead of the typical gin
so what we'll do is uh it's belvedere
vodka creme de violet uh luxardo
maracino uh liqueur and then a little
bit of lemon juice that is so fun we're
about to wrap up here so i'll have you
finish up the cocktail and just real
quick let's tell people where they can
celebrate what you guys are doing how
they can be part of it so you can
celebrate in all of our awesome
restaurants hanks at botiglia baracha
tides lucky penny cafe and don't forget
to visit us at the drop bar all on
saturday fireworks at 9 00 pm awesome
it's going to be such a fun party i'm
grabbing this drink because we are
celebrating early this is so much fun i
can't wait to come by i'm going to be
there to hang out and celebrate with you
guys happy 20 years be sure to check out
green valley ranch this looks delicious
thank you